pascal in your book you mentioned that
he had
a quotation about the whole point of
reason i believe it was reason not
rationality
but let's imagine it's reason that the
whole point of reason is to realize that
there's an infinitude of
more important aspects to life than
reason and then i was wondering
well what does one say to the
retort that when giving and
when giving a reason to not use reason
you're still appealing to reason
so it's somewhat self-defeating how do
you get out of that
um i didn't quite catch the meaning of
your last
remark let's say you're giving let's say
you're explaining to someone here's why
you shouldn't use reason
alone or if it's rationality alone but
either way you're giving
argument and giving a reason to well
there are different levels of reason and
there's a kind of meta level of reason
and i think the meta level the
overarching view that takes in both is
usually the one i
would say is best associated more likely
to be associated with the
working of the right hemisphere and so
as i say the right hemisphere is no
stranger to reason absolutely not
um and it would be a big mistake to say
that it in any way rejected it
but it's more likely to see the limits
of it because it's
it's able to stand outside of its own
viewpoint and see there are things that
it doesn't know which the left
hemisphere is very
bad at doing so it thinks i've got this
schema which will solve all my problems
i run them through
this mental computer and the solution
comes out which is the right answer
and the right hemispheres can say no
there could be many right answers that
are not you know they're not necessarily
compatible with one another
but they might apply in different
circumstances at different times with
different people
so to see a more nuanced and
more complex picture i think the right
hemisphere is the the one that would be
using elements of reason
and there's nothing wrong with reason in
itself to show the limits of reason this
is really what pascal was saying
and you've just demonstrated that that
is that is okay
he made a distinction between what he
called geometry
geometers and esprit
fine spirits and he says the fine
spirits and by the word
fine he means subtle so the subtle
spirit
is different from the slightly bull in
the china shop black and white hard and
fast
inflexible geometric spirit in which
he's saying you know you you you turn
away
you do a diagram and you've you've got
the answer whereas the
the esp he says can
see things understand things that can
hardly be put into words but are
very very important now coming from a
mathematician that is a very imp
and a very great mathematician that's a
very important thing to hear